this is curtain divina reading for mark
delaney as a lover of all things undead
i rank 2015's dying light in the upper
tier of zombie sagas it builds on the
rpg light framework of techland's
previous effort dead island with better
writing and the exciting new element of
parkour thus 2018's reveal of dynalite 2
was a big deal for me but the years
since have seen the game's prospects
take blow after blow due to in-house
controversies and several delays now the
team at techland has only a few short
months before the sequel's february 4th
release date but this one might just
stick to landing i was able to check out
a portion of the game spanning four
hours of hands on time in two regions
and across two platforms and while i
have questions still to answer on my own
time i'm left feeling fairly confident
that this will be a better game than the
great original even as many of its new
toys come from other open world games
the build i played was about a month old
and kicked off in the game's opening
region of old vilidor this was as the
lead game designer explained it a tamer
region meant to allow players to get
grips to the game's melee combat and
parkour moves and come to understand how
to manage crowds of infected and
survivors alike the first thing i
realized when i started playing dying
light 2 was how fluid the movement felt
smart changes like faster strafing and
back pedaling and an always-on sprint
ability make the anti-hero protagonist
aiden caldwell feel more adept at
performing his death-defying feats than
kyle crane ever was
he's lighter on his feet and animations
are smoother even from the get-go and
despite me seeing some really
tantalizing skills not yet unlocked
during my play sessions i especially
loved how quickly i was able to intuit
whether or not i could make any
particular jump the mechanics are
improved across the board and give the
controls a faster more reliable feeling
in my hands the original dying light
felt great in 2015 and for the most part
still did when i went back to it to
refresh my memory a few weeks ago now
i'm ready for what's new the
environments feel like they have many
more opportunities for creative
parkouring more ledges to climb the
sides of buildings like its first person
assassin's creed more ways to scale the
world like ropes to swing on and winches
to fling you upward and better spaced
objects that promise leaping before
looking isn't always going to be fatal
like it was before the lead game
designer told me that parkour was the
thing that techland thought it could
bring to the crowded zombie genre even
beyond games the freedom of movement is
what set crane's story apart from not
just dayz or left 4 dead but also things
like max brooks's world war z book or
romero's dawn of the dead in dying light
2 the signature element seems to be
markedly better while parkour feels like
a strength being made stronger the first
game's story wasn't as impressive so
there's arguably even more room for
dying light 2 to grow there based on my
time with it so far i'd say things are
more interesting even if still a bit
uneven the somewhat muted emotions each
character wears on their face is not a
new issue to rpgs bethesda has been
getting by with virtual mannequins for
decades but dying light 2 doesn't look
like it will break that mold similarly
with so many characters to meet from
merchants to major players and
everything in between i've already seen
a wide array of performances and
characterizations a father-son pair of
italian traders feel especially like
caricatures i do wish the game would go
all in on its fascinating modern dark
ages setting and stick to the more
serious stuff but as before it seems
techland will mix in plenty of offbeat
characters who may screw with the
overall tone more than i'd personally
enjoy where the story does seem to have
improved is in its emphasis on player
choices and consequences according to
the lead game designer this was the
hardest part of development leading me
to understand that beyond the ousted
writers and covet obstacles teclan has
simply had its hands full trying to keep
all possible stories on their tracks
major choices mostly appear to be binary
and often revolve around siding with one
of two factions the ragtag survivors or
the authoritative peacekeepers binary
choices can feel a bit dated in 2021
given that so many games have moved on
to swim in grayer waters but even if the
system isn't revolutionary it does seem
to improve this particular series it
never allowed for this type of player
agency before save for a dramatic final
scene each decision i was told changes a
great deal of what players can see in
the game from that point on some
characters will simply cease to exist
and close off narrative branches for
players on top of altering the story
you'll alter the world around you an
early decision i made would have given
me car alarm traps with which i could
distract the infected but as i sided
with the survivors i instead saw zip
lines installed across the city there
seemed to be about 10 major decisions to
make according to an unlocked tree i saw
meaning going down opposite paths across
two playthroughs would result in starkly
different cities in the end sometimes
changes will reveal consequences hours
later which i saw when i made it to the
game's second major region the central
loop with its high-rise buildings taller
than anything the series has ever
featured as my last mission demanded i
screwed across an open area quickly i
relied on my newly installed ziplines to
beat the enemies to their would-be
explosive finale had i sided with the
peacekeepers earlier i not have been
stranded but my particular solution
wouldn't have worked and i would have
had to find another way across the
devil's playground the ziplines felt
like the right call in that moment but
of course if the concept fulfills its
promise there will be times in the game
where i'll wish i had those car alarm
traps instead along with these major
inflection points dynalite 2 rounds out
its story with more dialogue options so
even side missions and briefer
interactions can change your course in
some ways
it's not just about the major story
beats things like an awesome glider that
can open on demand many more enemy types
especially among the zombies and ample
distractions via multi-colored mini map
markers signal that this is a game built
on its own sturdy foundation but with
many of the tools of open world
predecessors dying light didn't have a
ton to do beyond the critical path and
those sandbox players have seen its new
toys before i can say as a fan of the
series that i'm glad to see the sequel's
world is filled in a lot more
dying light 2 feels familiar but not in
a bad way the additions be it the
original or derivative tend to feel like
good fits for this world and because the
game's most special aspect the parkour
movement abilities are clearly improved
it feels like dying light 2 is both a
bigger and better sequel blatantly
inspired by juggernauts such as the
witcher zelda and assassin's creed in
different parts dying light too still
feels like it will manage to leave its
mark on the sandbox formula with the
fluidity of a fountain the exciting
parkour should prove to be its signature
when dying light 2 launches next
february
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
you